so you mentioned a conversation that you
had about work and how it's good work or
bad work has never really finished and
you know we're in this new age of these
sort of gurus and these like success
articles on you know five tips to make
you more productive whatever so
something David was talking about was a
sustained obsession he said that he'd
read and heard from so many people that
most successful people are just obsessed
with their work they're workaholics you
think that's true there's a lot of truth
in it and I've gone through that same
thought process especially when writing
a book about the creative mind and I
don't think that workaholics is the
right word for it I call it the Type C
personality and because the workaholics
comes from the concept of the selya's
concepts of the type A and type B
personality and from what I can make out
the type A personality is the unhappy
workaholic who can't do anything in life
except work and who basically is making
himself and the people around him
miserable because of his work is this
obsessive need to be working all the
time and then there's a type P
personality who never is very well
defined and and somehow doesn't become
an ideal SL yeh describes him but is
somebody who's well adjusted and doesn't
feel the same crazy pressures that the
Type A feels and I thought well the
problem with that theory is that it
leaves out people who absolutely love
their work and who are able to live you
know other full lives at the same time
and I started thinking about that and
realizing there are a lot of people like
that and there I call them type sees in
one of my books and the type C is the
creative personality that loves to work
would probably be rather be working than
anything else but isn't negatively
impacted by that at all instead they
just thrive on their work I mean there's
example I saw a long ago as Pablo Casals
the great you know cellist was so
crippled with arthritis when he got to
be older that he had to be carried
his bed every morning to his piano bench
and because he warmed up everyday by
playing a piano for half an hour an hour
and but but he got to the point where he
couldn't walk to the bench he had to be
carried to the bench and then stacked on
to his bench and his arms had to be
lifted onto the keyboard and then he
would slowly but surely start playing
for an hour and at the end of the hour
he got up and walked to you know to the
kitchen for breakfast and he did this
every day in his last ten years and he
was reactivating his body through the
Curia - you know the creative process
that he was very well in tune with and I
realized that type-c personalities are
people who have this you know creative
affliction or whatever you call it this
gift and but but understand it as
opposed to those who don't understand it
and who have often tragic endings like
Sylvia Plath or Hemingway or Virginia
Woolf or many others in the creative
world who never understand their process
who think that every time they finish a
book it's the end of the world and they
go into a deep depression this is very
common in the creative world is to be
depressed after you finish your work so
when you really think about that do the
solution is obvious never get to the
point where you're finishing the work
and that happens on the negative side
for a lot of people can never finish
their book or never finish their article
or never finish their poem because
they're afraid of finishing fear of
finishing and and as a tenured professor
I was always on committees judging other
people who couldn't finish anything and
one of my colleagues who like me had
published many books we were both on the
same committee judging another Kawa
colleague who had not finished a single
book and my colleagues said to me you
know you and I would would write a book
in the time it takes him to research a
chapter of a book and I said yeah
because I
always through my research last you know
I write the book first Linda to research
and so I already know it's going to end
but and to get back to this finishing
idea of finishing a simple solution to
this postpartum depression is to when
you know that you're almost done when
you know that you're and the homestretch
of a book or of a screenplay or whatever
it is stop take a day off take two days
off because the energy of finishing is
so huge that it will easily be recalled
when you sit down again to allow it into
this compartment that you're using but
take a day off instead and it starts
your next project truly get into your
next project because every creative
person has another project that's dying
to be next so sit down and start it and
go on it do it to the point where you
can't wait to go on with it and then
stop and go back and finish the project
you were finishing and you'll discover
that there is no no no more any
postpartum depression because you
haven't allowed it you simply managed
the time you know the finite commodity
at your disposal
you've managed the time so you don't
have to deal with that because being
depressed is basically most of the time
a waste of time for an artist you can
allow it for a while if it gives you
great ideas and deepens your pathos and
the things that you need to draw on but
it's basically too much of it as a waste
of time and you know one of my mentors
years ago John Gardner the novelist said
people should just start doing more it
gets rid of all the moods they're having
you know if you're in a down mood get up
and run around the block and literally
that works I mean if you get your body
going and run around the block it's hard
to be in that kind of morbid depressed
state you're in before so managing your
moods like that it's what separates a
productive happy creative person from a
productive unhappy creative person
you notice I'm not talking about the
unproductive ones that's a whole
different subject but I'm talking about
people who are creatively productive and
have careers they're still divided into
the unhappy ones and the happy ones and
it's a matter of understanding I think
how your mind is working that makes you
part of the happy group and you don't
have to be part of the unhappy group
despite a lot of urban myths to the
contrary that basically say the artists
got to be suffering and tortured and all
of that that's really not necessary you
get more attention that way I know Julia
Cameron talks about and I'm butchering
this I'm sure but that the unhappy
blocked artist gets a lot of attention
and Pat's on the back and friends around
them where is the productive happier
person finds themselves sometimes alone
because it's a little threatening or
it's it's just hard to you know yeah but
being alone is wonderful so happy and
the happy productive what artist loves
being alone and he loves being with
people too but loves being alone because
that's truly when he's are under the
most command of all of his powers and
facilities when nothing can interrupt
him and he's focused on the work that's
great and getting too much sympathy I
mean as the literary manager who's
managed hundreds of writers over my
career I think that you the ones who are
unhappy and looking for attention you
really get tired of them fast if you're
dealing with them all the time I mean if
they're in your family and everything
and you only have to see them once a
week okay fine you only have to see them
at Thanksgiving dinner okay even better
but if you're you know somebody who
deals with them every day sooner or
later the ones who are constantly
complaining go on to your life as to a
short list and those are not the ones
you're looking for and they're what I
call pseudo artists who ends up end up
not being productive most of the time
you know who but who are longing to be
artists but don't have the mental
discipline to to actually do it
you